well if
the brooklyn nets could win if the game
is 90 points or less
if it goes over 90 and start going into
the 100s they can't win
just because you know you you just
you can't get enough baskets because you
don't have the the
proficiency that milwaukee would have
now when kyrie
and james are out there you want to you
want to get 110 possessions
you want to get as many possessions you
can because if we take 110 shots and you
take 110
we're going to beat you we got better
shooters better players so
now we've got to slow it down and say
like
when kevin durant in the last four
minutes of the game it's 85-80
now he could take us home but if you're
trying to still get
110 112 points you will not beat
the milwaukee bucks i i cannot see that
to me this is the defining
moment of this bucks team
this is the defining moment in my
opinion
there's no way if they look if like shaq
said
unless uh joe harris mike james
and blake are diving all over the place
but it don't matter they don't have
enough talent to beat the bucks team
if i'm the milwaukee bucks i'll get
together guys
this is our moment as long as they don't
outwork us
they can't beat us because they can't
score enough points and if the milwaukee
bucks
lose this series without
james harden for the entire series now
know kyrie
this will be one of the biggest choke
jobs in basketball history
history history history yes for history
i'm with you on that joke i'm serious if
the debate they'll be
to play the entire series without james
and be 2-2
and no james and kyrie if you can't beat
these guys
two out of three games this will be one
of the biggest choke jobs in nba history
game five tomorrow night right here tnt
eight o'clock eastern time for that half
hour pregame show